lui aussi va mener campagne mais pour
décrocher la 1re circonscription du
loiret cher marc fesneau fouetter
passage hier à mort et une première
sortie en local pour le tout nouveau
ministre de l'agriculture
une visite dans les allées du comice
agricole du nord du loir-et-cher après
une annulation en 2020 et en 2021
l'événement était donc de retour ce week
end 60 éleveurs et 160 exposants réunis
pour défendre le monde agricole et le
valoriser auprès du grand public
ambiance avec florent que la belle
au comice agricole de mort est un cheval
percheron d'une tonne pour deux mètres
de haut et des mini animaux comme
biscotte biquettes star auprès des
enfants à la dent les câlins être prêt
nous avec nous travail et du temps avec
nous car ça ça remporté un vif succès
pour mettre dans son terrain parce que
cette petite holtz a fait pas peur
ça ne mange pas beaucoup ça peut
entretenir une parcelle herbeuse à la
maison toc c'est surtout décoratifs on
voit tout au comice agricole du nord du
loir et cher et ça depuis le 19e siècle
organisé tous les dix ans cette vitrine
de l'agriculture locale a dû être
repoussé en 2020 puis 2021 de retour
cette année grâce à la volonté des
bénévoles et de la commune l'événement a
été monté en trois petits mois à peine
ça a été la tour ce dans tous les sens
en 2010 on était six ans bénévole
aujourd'hui c'est que 200 on y arrive et
on a fait avec c'est une tradition c'est
on est né nu à de parents agriculteurs
ça fait découvrir tout le monde agricole
tout le monde agricole des animaux aux
premiers pas de la mécanisation comme
avec ces tracteurs du début du 20e
siècle on a connu ça en était gamin mais
depuis
c'est loin ont réservé pour conduisent à
vue on les a vu qu'on était des gammes
heure ou une heure on rêvait en avoir un
mais après ça a été le dernier pour son
retour le comice agricole de mort et a
réussi à attirer plus de 30000 visiteurs
un succès populaire